a black belt in karate his own form of
martial arts not to mention dozens of TV
appearances playing iconic characters
Jason David Frank the actor and martial
artist behind Tommy Oliver the memorable
Green Ranger from Mighty Morphin Power
Rangers has died keep watching to find
out more about his legacy Jason David
Frank's representative Justine hunt
confirmed to TMZ that the actor died in
Texas and is survived by his four
children he was 49. several alumni from
the Power Rangers franchise including
Black Ranger actor and co-star Walter
Emanuel Jones took to social media to
grieve over Frank's passing while
speaking with TMZ Jones described his
former Mighty Morphin co-star as a quote
inspiration to many and fondly
remembered how the Green Ranger was one
of the biggest pranksters on the show
following the release of Mighty Morphin
Power Rangers in 1993 Frank quickly
became the poster child of the franchise
with the Green Ranger emerging as one of
the most popular characters on the show
that's a green ranger Oliver began as a
villain under Rita repulses spell meant
to destroy the Power Rangers following
his defeat at the hands of the Red
Ranger Oliver decided to use his powers
for good joining the titular team with
his cocky attitude and tendency to
operate as a lone wolf the Green Ranger
frequently clashed with leadership and
expectations Oliver's Ark later saw him
assuming the role of the noble white
ranger becoming the leader of the team
following the finale of Mighty Morphin
Power Rangers Frank went on to portray
Oliver countless times and several
spin-offs continuing his fan favorites
Arc 2004's Power Rangers Dino Thunder
saw Tommy as a mature and sensible
leader for a new generation of Power
Rangers as the fandoms saw the character
grow on Dino Thunder they were treated
to Tommy stepping into the shoes of the
Beloved Black Ranger Frank's final
performance as Tommy Oliver was in
2018's Power Rangers super Ninja Steel
which coincided with the 25th
anniversary of the mega franchise fans
will always remember Frank as the
emotional anchor for the entire
franchise and while he will always be
remembered as a green ranger there was
more to the actor than just Power
Rangers in a way playing Tommy Oliver
was more of Frank's side hustle with his
day job being professional martial arts
the actor made headlines in 2010 when he
made and won his MMA debut after signing
on to Sucker Punch entertainment prior
to his professional career as a fighter
the Green Ranger actor had a number of
amateur fights under his belt his
passion for martial arts eventually led
to the fighter opening up his own Karate
Dojo Rising Sun karate located just
outside of Houston Texas the school
teaches Frank's unique and personally
developed form of martial arts toso
kundo which translates to way of the
fighting fist boasting an 8th degree
black belt Frank managed and taught at
the Texas karate school since its
Inception Frank's bio on the official
Rising Sun karate website reveals that
the Green Ranger began studying martial
arts at the age of four and has won
multiple accolades including the coveted
Arnold Schwarzenegger Classics Master
appreciation award Beyond karate Frank
achieved a purple belt in Brazilian Jiu
Jitsu and trained with several revered
martial artists including Muay Thai
instructor Master toddy who previously
trained fighter and actor Gina Carano
prior to his passing in 2022 Frank
confirmed that he had officially retired
from his nearly three decade long stints
as the Green Ranger and had intentions
to work on more mature projects all in
all Frank appeared as a green ranger
over a dozen times and while his legacy
as a Power Ranger is Indescribable his
contributions to the World of Martial
Arts should be celebrated just as well
foreign
[Music]